Keri Russell is pregnant and rocking a  baby bump onset et has the pics Keri  Russell is going to be a mom again the  American actress is expecting her first  child with co-star Matthew Reese on  Wednesday Carrie was spotted filming on  the set of the hit FX series she's  covered up in a large coat but it  appears there's a noticeable baby bump a  source close to the star confirms the  actress is indeed pregnant and et has  reached out to the couple's reps for  comment 41 year old Matthew and a 39  year old Kari went to public with the  relationship in April 2014 and this new  addition will join 8 year old River and  a four year old Willa carries children  with her ex-husband Shane Deary the two  divorced in 2013